The year 2012 proved to be an inflection point for online shopping in India.
Online shopping trends on Google grew by a hundred and twenty-eight percent...
...over the previous year.
The year 2013 also promises to see triple-digit year-on-year growth of this trend.
Google India and TNS Australia undertook a study...
...to get a deeper insight into the key drivers of this growth.
Here's a look at what Google search trends and the study indicate.
Validating the growth in trends,...
...nine out of ten e-commerce buyers intend to spend more on online shopping this year.
The areas that would contribute to growth include a greater contribution from non-metros.
A greater number of queries will originate from mobile phones.
We expect a shift in what the shoppers are buying.
Apparel and accessories as a category emerged as one of the most purchased category.
In 2013, this category will overtake electronics...
...to become the leading category for online shopping.
We expect to see increasing contributions from new emerging categories...
...such as baby products, home decor furnishing and health and nutrition.